horror movies are always at their best
when the third act goes a little off the
rails thriller endings are supposed to
leave us feeling either satisfied or
completely unsatisfied and nowhere in
between so when a scary movie actually
delivers that grand finale that ties all
its terror tricks together it can be
pretty unforgettable let's take a look
back at some of those horror flicks that
really stuck the landing before the turn
of the millennium and it should go
without saying spoilers for these old
movies lay ahead The Omen directed by
Richard Donner The Omen features one of
the most iconic villains of all time
Damien thorn a pint-sized Antichrist
destined to rule the world adopted by an
American ambassador Damien is
indoctrinated by his satanic nanny soon
the body count starts stacking up after
realizing his adopted kid is actually
the son of Satan
daddy thorne takes Damien to a church
and plans to go full-bore biblical on
him we're talking Abraham and Isaac
[Music]
however before he can finish the
dastardly deed the cops show up and
opened fire after the gun smoke clear as
we cut to a funeral
but unfortunately for mankind Damien is
alive and well
it's thorne who's Six Feet Under and in
a satanic twist of fate Damien has been
adopted by Thorne's old buddy the
President of the United States
Damien looks directly at the camera and
gives an eerie smile that had easily
prevent anyone watching from ever
wanting kids invasion of the Body
Snatchers in Phillip Kaufman's invasion
of the body snatchers remake Donald
Sutherland plays a San Francisco health
inspector named Matthew ben'll who's
drawn into a bizarre conspiracy
involving an evil alien race these
extraterrestrials are creating
doppelgangers of every human on earth
and their plan is to absorb victims
while they sleep and create emotionless
doubles using plant-like pods the
process is horrifying
naturally this doesn't sit well with
fennel and a small group of survivors
who desperately try to stay awake to
avoid having their body snatched the
group also discovers they can fool the
aliens by acting cool and detached but
if they show an ounce of emotion the pod
people emit a high pitch scream to alert
their fellow aliens it sounds like this
ben'll does his best to prevent the bad
guys from spreading their pods across
the world but there's no stopping the
invasion at the end of the film it
appears that ben'll is hiding from the
bad guys in plain sight surviving by
impersonating the pod people
but as he leaves his office one day he
runs into an old friend who's still
human and that's when this happens
Friday the 13th the horror genre is full
of last-minute gotcha moments from the
graveyard dream and carried to the
return of Freddy and a Nightmare on Elm
Street but as good as those are Friday
the 13th finish stands decapitated head
and shoulders above the rest
this slasher classic follows a bunch of
teenage counselors fooling around at a
summer camp when a mysterious maniac
turns up slashing folks with every sharp
instrument known to man
eventually the culprit is revealed to be
an angry mrs. Voorhees a former camp
cook who wants revenge against all
counselors for letting her deformed son
drown in Crystal Lake decades ago
luckily final girl Alice neck chops mrs.
Voorhees and escapes the camp by
climbing into a canoe and sailing on to
the lake she falls asleep before
reaching the shore and when she wakes up
it's a beautiful day the cops have
arrived and it seems like she's finally
safe and that's when a waterlogged Jason
jumps out of the lake and pulls Alice
down with him Alice later wakes up in a
hospital with no sign of Jason anywhere
but she's not convinced he was some
figment of her fatigued imagination no
one believed her then put the Dozen
films to follow certainly proved she was
right about that the thing directed by
John Carpenter the thing is a brutally
cynical sci-fi film that follows a group
of American scientists trapped inside an
Antarctic Research Station they're being
hunted by a shape-shifting alien that
absorbs its victims and creates
identical copies so in addition to
battling this otherworldly beast our
heroes are also dealing with a serious
case of paranoia by the film's last act
the titular thing has slain almost
everyone in the camp with the exception
of McCready a bearded helicopter pilot
who blows the creature to kingdom come
unfortunately he sets the entire base on
fire in the process as he sits alone in
the wreckage that's when child's
McCready's old frenemy steps in the guy
vanished during the climactic showdown
with the thing and now
he isn't sure if child's as human
anymore the two are in a standoff and as
the cold sets in they share a bottle of
whiskey and wait for someone or
something to make the next move leaving
us to wonder if our heroes will make it
out alive or if they're even heroes
anymore if you're gonna punctuate a pic
with a question mark this is how it's
done don't look now after their daughter
tragically drowns at their English
estate John and Laura Baxter find
themselves trapped in a spiral of grief
devastated they moved to Venice where
they encountered two creepy sisters who
claim they can see the little girl's
spirit Laura believes the psychic
siblings but John is skeptical
nevertheless he does notice that
something weird is going on there's a
mysterious little figure running around
town wearing the same red coat his
daughter had on when she drowned there
are also rumors of a serial Slayer in
the area strangers still after his wife
returns to England on an emergency visit
John inexplicably spots her writing a
funeral boat down a Venetian canal
John's unease grows until he spots the
girl in red one last time hoping that
maybe it's the ghost of his daughter he
follows the cloaked figure only to
realize it's actually a monstrous dwarf
armed with a meat cleaver this is who's
been dropping victims in the grand canal
she plants her knife right into John's
neck and as his body violently convulses
John realizes the vision of his wife on
a funeral boat was actually a
premonition of his own demise but
there's nothing he can do about it as he
bleeds out on the floor a victim of
grief guilt and one ugly monster talk
about a tragic twist in the mouth of
madness equal parts HP Lovecraft and
Stephen King in the mouth of madness
will make you feel like you're losing
your mind in it John Trent is an
insurance investigator hired by a
publishing company to track down
best-selling authors Sutter cane the
writer has mysteriously vanished taking
his new novel with him but his Trent
digs deeper into the case he learns that
Kane is no average author see Kane has
millions of loyal followers around the
world who worship as novels which gives
him the power to bring his characters to
life were still Kane's new book will
drive people mad and turn them into
monsters it's all part of a scheme to
destroy the human race and subject
humanity to the rule of
gods but before Cain can accomplish his
plan he wants Trent to deliver his now
finished manuscript to his publisher and
Trent has to obey because he's actually
one of Cain's characters obviously Trent
refuses to believe he was dreamed up for
some book but soon enough Cain's novel
has turned the world into a mutated
madhouse with society crumbling around
him and his mind slowly slipping
Trent winds up in a movie theater and
watches the film adaptation of Cain's
book as it turns out Trent is the main
character and everything that's just
happened to him is playing on the big
screen realising his life is a Sutter
cane creation Trent snaps laughing
hysterically before weeping
uncontrollably but hey at least he has
the entire theater to himself the Blair
Witch Project nearly 20 years later it's
easy to forget how big a deal The Blair
Witch Project was when it first debuted
in 1999 it revolutionized viral
marketing introduced the found-footage
fad to the mainstream and totally mess
people up with it's incredibly freaky
ending after heading into the woods to
make a documentary about the local
legend of the Blair Witch three college
students
Heather Mike and Josh find themselves
completely lost and wandering in circles
I gave you back the map they soon
discover spooky stick figures hanging
from branches here creepy kids giggling
at night and then Josh mysteriously
disappears leaving only a few teeth and
a piece of his tongue behind
soon after Mike and Heather hear him
screaming in the distance and they
follow the sound to an abandoned house
camera in hand Heather makes her way
into the basement and finds her friend
standing in a corner which is how a
child Slayer of local legend would
position his victims that's when someone
or something attacks her from behind and
the camera falls to the ground still
recording for several seconds before it
stops psycho it's a bit of a shock in
psycho when the main character Marion
crane is suddenly and violently
dispatched in the middle of the film but
things take an even crazier turn when
it's revealed that the culprit is hotel
manager Norman Bates in drag
having offed his own mother years ago
the disturbed motel clerk suffers from a
split personality that causes him to act
like his evil mom and stab unsuspecting
victims as they shower
we all go a little mad sometimes
Norman is eventually captured and tossed
into a cell where he completely
transforms into his domineering mother
huddled beneath a blanket with his mom's
voice running through his head Norman
looks at the audience and gives a
chilling grin as mrs. Bates skull
flashes over his face proving that there
is no more Norman only mom we then cut
back to the Bates Motel where the cops
are towing Marian's car out of a swamp
leaving the viewer to wonder how many
more cars will be found down there Night
of the Living Dead this seminal zombie
film has a simple plot one fateful day
corpses rise up from the ground and boy
are they hungry soon a small band of
survivors find themselves trapped inside
an old farmhouse desperately fighting
the zombie horde not to mention their
own growing fears and rivalries
eventually there's only one survivor
left a black man named Ben who wakes up
the next morning after hearing a volley
of gunshots in the distance cautious but
hopeful Ben peers out the window
spotting an all-white Posse outside
suddenly the gun-toting group sees Ben
and assuming he's a zombie
a gunman puts a bullet in his head
having survived an assault by an army of
flesh hungry fiends our hero is
ultimately defeated by the very people
who are supposed to keep him safe there
are a lot of social and political
undertones that can be drawn from the
ending but the film lets the scene speak
for itself a stroke of brilliance on
director George a Romero's part the
sixth sense in the movie to put M night
Shyamalan on the map we meet child
psychologist Malcolm Crowe who has some
unfinished business to attend to years
after failing to help a young patient
suffering from hallucinations he gets a
shot at redemption in the form of
nine-year-old Cole Cyr and folks Cole
has a heck of a problem Cole reveals
that the people he sees don't know they
aren't alive and while the doctor is
skeptical at first he quickly learns the
boy really does possess well a sixth
sense
realizing the spirits might need help
Crowe encourages called to communicate
with the ghosts and come to terms with
his gift meanwhile Crowe has grown
distant from his wife and at the end of
the movie he sits beside his sleeping
bride which is when the directors famous
knack for twist kicks in in her sleep
Crowes wife asks why he left her and
then dropped something on the floor
it's Crowes wedding rings the one
thought he was wearing during the whole
film suddenly crow remembers that a
disgruntled patient the one he'd failed
so long ago actually ended his life
before doing the same to himself crow
has been a ghost all along and the clues
were everywhere it doesn't get much
better than that thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]